let's come over here now now it bits of
silat similarities doesn't it
for example what are the intersects now
there are two reasons for that
you should draw them in the first reason
is the same thing is happening over here
there are two numbers and only two
numbers whose squares are themselves and
as your own one okay but the other thing
is that a square root of x and x squared
these two themselves have a relationship
with each other what we call these guys
start to add I Wow
any word that started on a.m. mats okay
these are inverses of each other
are they not okay inverses I had I had
two layers yeah anyway they're inverse
functions and that means that you're
reflecting across this y equals x line
right so therefore you put two
intersections they say because they are
on the reflection one okay what else
okay so then they value fine you can
square negative as it's all good but
something happens to the that maybe
advised me to square them right what
happens to them where are they going
yeah they've come up to the top because
of course when you square all those
values in the real world I'm going to be
positive so that's why we have that guy
okay one last thing I want to do is here
we said if you have a value in fact this
is probably worth writing down right for
0 is less than X is less than or is less
than 1 that's right
the square root of x is going to be
bigger vinick's do you go that whereas
for X is greater than 1 the square root
of x is less than it's smaller
okay what not only here how can we
explain what's going on from doctor 1
very good ex sweat is less than X
because you square a number if little
and it gets cut really I suppose if your
square fraction like like a quarter or
an eight-point-two or something like
that then yes it will get smaller
whereas if you take a big double right
then when you square it of course you're
going to get something
manja okay now these don't just apply to
X these apply to any functions that you
square or take the square root on so for
example if I say instead of this right
if my function right whatever that
happens to be is less than one then the
square root of that function will be
bigger and the function do you see that
so this is just staying generally here
or we look at for y equals x in the same
way when a function when the function
values are both one you take the square
root and you'll be less than the
original function yes it's a great
question and the reason why is because
you're not actually looking at the X
values this is f of X right this is f of
X which is why it's just I've just
relabeled it right y equals f of X so in
fact this is another way to say why
first is the other Y but rather than
saying the other way I'll just tell them
what the labels are okay in the same way
and here I can say if your function is
between not one then if you square that
function swear it then it's going to be
less right does that make sense whereas
if your function is bigger than one if
you square that function well of course
you expect things to
because when you spray them with their
becomes